über 40 jahre war das syrische volk
sturm bis 2011 wo keine
kriegsberichterstatter sind bedienen
sich die menschen ihre handys es sind
hilferufe an die welt eine art moderner
flaschenpost mir noch das ist nicht bloß
informationen da ist gefühl leiden
es ist ein notruf goal erzählt von liebe
und dem gefühl dass horst all das sieht
man in jedem einzelnen bild für mich war
es der beginn einer neuen film kunst
seit zwei jahren lebt osama mohammed in
paris als exilant ein getriebener
auf der suche nach dokumenten anonymer
filme aus seiner heimat
es sind 1000 und ein blick auf die
gräuel des bürgerkriegs aufwühlende
bilder von tod und folter
osama mohammed schlüpft in die haut der
menschen hinter den handys erlebt ihren
albtraum mit
diese menschen haben im selben
augenblick gefilmt
die bilder übermittelt filming haben
gefilmt seien umgekommen und die bilder
gegen ins internet mit dem einzigen ziel
die aufnahmen zu retten aus der
belagerung aus syrien damit die
kontrolle des regimes zu überwinden
andrang unbedingt an die außenwelt zu
gelangen den authentischen
handyaufnahmen stellt der regisseur
seine bilder und gedanken gegenüber fern
der heimat fühlte er sich ständig als
versager bevor ich mit dem film begann
fühlte ich mich jeden tag schuldig
gemacht
was sonst waren sich nur hirschau all
die bilder an und konstruiere einen film
in meiner vorstellung
eine ampel an da kontaktiert in einer
jungen frau
paris
sie filmt im belagerten homs und fragt
ihn um unterstützung an
sie befand sich in lebensgefahr
ich war psychisch angeschlagen dieser
kontakt wohnt mir ein fenster zurück ins
leben und zurück nach syrien
es war als ob ich wieder dort wählen
sie mal bei dir schon sagte später sie
habe nur dank der kamera überlebt mal
war die kamera ihre mutter mal ihr vater
vor einem monat sind sich die beiden zum
ersten mal begegnet als co autoren des
films zur erstaufführung und kann mit
dem wunsch die geschichte hinter den
bildern jedes einzelnen anonymen films
ins kino zu tragen